(dramatic music begins)
- [Newsman] The president's
car is now turning
on to Elm Street in open limousine parade.
(gunshot fires)
- [Johnny] There's a cover-up
that's about to happen here.
- [Newsman] This is a
situation and I read,
"Kennedy is shot in head."
- [Johnny] The
assassination of a president
and then a scramble by the U.S. government
to hide information from its people.
- So much information was
hid from the American public.
- [Lyndon] How many, how many,
how many shots were fired?
- [J. Edgar] Three.
- [Johnny] The question
of who shot JFK and why
has riveted America since that
horrifying day 60 years ago.
But over time, it's become
clear that the FBI and CIA
kept information hidden,
not just from the public,
but from the commission
in charge of investigating
the assassination.
This has fueled an understandable doubt
in the official account,
including, by the way, Lyndon B. Johnson,
the president who took JFK's place.
Congress even came out
in the '80s saying that
this was probably a conspiracy,
and the public ran wild with this.
They came up with hundreds of suspects
of who could have been
involved in the assassination.
Theories like this thrive
when government authorities
aren't transparent with their people.
So let me show you how this happened.
Let me explain the official story
and why that story has been
hit with a wave of doubt
over the decades
and explain that unlike a
lot of conspiracy theories,
doubting the official story here
isn't as crazy as you might think.
(tense dramatic music)
- [Journalist] This was a turning
point in American history.
People all of a sudden decided,
"I'm not sure they're
telling us the truth."
- JFK is this really
symbolic character who lived
during a very, very important
time in American history,
and the story really
dives into the context
of what it was like to be
in America in the '60s.
I'm really excited to dive in
and show you all of the stuff.
I need to thank the
sponsor of today's video.
Sponsors allow us to do
these super deep dives
that take months to make with
lots of different people,
so thank you, BetterHelp,
for sponsoring the video.
I'm a true believer in therapy.
BetterHelp makes therapy
more accessible to people
using technology.
It is a platform where you sign up,
you fill out information about yourself,
about what you're struggling with,
about what you want to achieve,
and then it matches you with
somebody in their network.
It's this giant network
of tens of thousands
of licensed therapists who
then you can be communicating
with one of those therapists
in as little as 48 hours.
You can communicate
with them on the phone,
which is what I do, I do phone therapy,
you can do it over video call,
or you can do it over text.
If the therapist they match
you with isn't a good fit,
you can easily be matched with a new one
to try someone else out.
It makes therapy accessible, affordable,
and in my mind,
de-stigmatizes this thing that
we all probably need and don't know it.
At least that's how I feel.
If you do want to sign up or try it out,
you can get a discount.
There's a link in my description.
It is betterhelp.com/johnnyharris.
When you click the link, it
helps support the channel,
but it also gets you in on a 10% discount
for your first month of BetterHelp.
So you can try it out at a discount,
see if it works for you,
and you can cancel any time if not.
Thank you, BetterHelp, for
sponsoring today's video.
Let's dive back in to
this fascinating story
of what happened to JFK.
(typewriter keyboard clacking)
(tense suspenseful music)
People loved John Kennedy.
He was this good-looking guy
who was always hanging out
with his beautiful family
and he just seemed to
instill a sense of confidence
in people.
Kennedy rode this positive
perception up the ranks
of American politics to
become the 35th president.
This was in the early '60s
when America was in a
giant time of transition.
- Oh, this is a revolution, of course,
that is sweeping our country now.
- The U.S. was the global superpower
and was locked in a Cold
War with another empire
a world away.
So JFK walks into the presidency
to find his military
and intelligence leaders
causing a lot of trouble around the world.
They had become very comfortable
with dangerous secrets.
They were funding wars,
they were overthrowing
governments in faraway countries,
they were assassinating leaders
that threatened American interests,
and they were doing most
of this totally in secret.
By the way,
if you wanna know more
about those CIA shenanigans,
go watch the video where
we map all the U.S. coups.
Anyway, JFK walks in and
sees this as "too much."
He wants to reign in these
spy and military leaders
from what he sees as an
abuse of American power.
He ended up firing and demoting
a bunch of these leaders,
a lot of these intel and military guys
who were plotting and
executing covert operations
around the world,
and he continued to pursue
like his ideal of world peace.
He chose diplomacy over violence.
When nuclear-armed missiles
were found in Cuba,
he slowed down the momentum
towards a full-scale presence in Vietnam
and he shut down several
of these covert operations
that were being planned
by the leaders around him.
This caused great tension between JFK
and America's military and spy leadership.
All of this context is important
when we look back on that
day in November 1963.
- [Newsman] Friday morning, 11:37,
the President's jet lands
at the Dallas Airport.
(typewriter keyboard clacking)
(tense suspenseful music)
- [Johnny] President Kennedy
and the Vice President Lyndon B. Johnson
arrived to Dallas for a speech
that the President was to give.
He got in this open-top
limousine with his wife, Jackie,
and the Texas governor, John Connally,
along with his wife, Nellie.
They rode through these streets,
downtown Dallas lined
with cheering spectators,
and then gunshots rang out.
(gunshot fires)
- [Newsman] Kennedy
apparently shot in head.
Blood was on his head.
- [Johnny] The shots hit the
President in the neck and head,
also wounding Governor Connally.
The President was rushed to the hospital
where he was pronounced dead.
- And very often, you'll find
a zipper hidden in the arm.
- Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
You'll excuse the fact
that I'm out of breath,
but President Kennedy and
Governor John Connally
have been cut down by assassins'
bullets in downtown Dallas.
The President has rushed
to Parkland Hospital.
(tense suspenseful music)
(typewriter keyboard clacking)
- [Johnny] Within hours
of the assassination,
the prime suspect became this
24-year-old former Marine,
a self-declared communist
who had renounced his American citizenship
and moved to the Soviet Union,
where he then fell disenchanted
with life in Russia
and move back to the U.S.
Eventually, ending up on the sixth story
of this building in Dallas where he worked
and where he was on
that morning in November
where he aimed a rifle
and shot the President.
His name was Lee Harvey Oswald.
And after these shots rang out, he fled.
While on the run, he shot and
killed a Dallas police officer
before hiding in a movie theater
and then eventually being arrested
at around 2:15 PM that day.
- I didn't shoot anybody, no, Sir.
- There was to be a trial,
and Oswald planned to plead not guilty,
claiming the whole thing
was actually a setup.
- I'm just a patsy.
- Patsy, which is like an old-timey term
for like the fall guy,
the one who was setup.
That same day, the vice
president, Lyndon B. Johnson,
was rushed back to the presidential plane
and sworn in as the new
president of the United States
before taking off and
heading back to Washington.
At the same time, the FBI,
the top investigatory body in our country,
descends onto Dallas.
And very quickly, the director
of the FBI, J. Edgar Hoover,
who's a big part of the story,
he comes to a conclusion
as to what happened.
This is before any investigation
had really gone forth.
And Hoover decides that Oswald
absolutely was the one who did it.
He was a communist sympathizer,
he was a frustrated misfit,
and crucially, he acted alone.
There was no one else.
Here's a phone call between Hoover
and the new president, LBJ.
- [J. Edgar] There's no question
but that he is the man now.
The fingerprints and things we have.
- I'd like some legal representation,
but you, police officers, have
not allowed me to have any.
- But luckily, we have a justice system
and we would find what
the facts actually say.
Oswald was going to stand trial
where the evidence could
be thoroughly examined,
where the country could see for themselves
who actually shot their President
and get closure on this horrifying event,
where whoever did it could
actually be brought to justice.
But that never happened.
Two days after the assassination,
while Oswald was being transferred
from police headquarters
to the county jail,
a nightclub owner named Jack Ruby
jumped out in front of the
crowd of police officers
and news reporters and shot Oswald.
(gunshot fires)
He was quickly rushed to the hospital
where he died soon after,
the same hospital where
President Kennedy had died
just 48 hours earlier.
- Lee Oswald has been shot.
- I think he got what he deserved,
if he's the one that did it.
- It is difficult to say
how long it will take
for the full realization of
what happened to really sink in.
- With Oswald dead,
there could be no trial,
no real sense of justice.
This left the government
investigators, the FBI mostly,
with the opportunity to
really own the narrative
of what happened.
The very next day,
the Deputy Attorney General
sends a memo to the White House
stressing that the
public must be satisfied
with this explanation
that Oswald acted alone.
He didn't have co-conspirators
that were still at large.
This had to be the story, and
I'll explain why in a sec.
This memo also included some wisdom
and kind of a foreshadow
of what was gonna happen
over the next several decades
where the memo urges the
White House to release
as much information as
possible to the public
so as to avoid public speculation.
Just remember that advice,
"Release the information to
avoid public speculation."
It's kinda the most
important part of the story.
We have these recently
released phone recordings
between the FBI director, J. Edgar Hoover,
and the new president, LBJ,
and we see in this phone call
that the FBI actually didn't
want a thorough investigation.
- [Lyndon] I think it
would be very, very bad
to have a rash of investigations.
- [J. Edgar] It'd be a three-ring circus.
- [Lyndon] Well, the only
way to stop them is probably
to appoint a high level one
to evaluate your report.
I can select out of the government,
and I could tell the House and Senate
not to go ahead with the investigation.
- [J. Edgar] Yes.
- LBJ creates this group
called the Warren Commission,
and you can see in these phone calls,
he was asking the FBI director
who should be on the Commission.
- [Lyndon] What do you
think about Allen Dulles?
- [J. Edgar] I think
he would be a good man.
- [Johnny] Wait, did you catch that?
Allen Dulles,
he was the former director of the CIA.
He's one of the guys that JFK fired
after he tried to overthrow
the Cuban government.
And now, he's about to be
appointed to the committee
investigating Kennedy's assassination.
This did nothing to instill
trust in the Commission.
- The new president appointed a Commission
of seven prominent Americans
to investigate the whole affair.
- [Lyndon] The Special
Commission will have before it
all the evidence uncovered
by the Federal Bureau
of Investigation and all the information
available to any agencies
of the Federal Government.
- The Warren Commission
was given just 10 months
to investigate this
situation using the evidence
that was mostly provided
to them by the FBI.
They produced this report,
which essentially confirms the conclusion
that J. Edgar Hoover, the
director of the FBI, had come to
in the hours and days
following the assassination,
that on November 22nd,
the shots fired that killed the President
and wounded the Governor
were fired by one guy,
Lee Harvey Oswald.
The report stresses that he acted alone.
They say it very definitively.
He nor the person who killed
him two days later, Jack Ruby,
were a part of any conspiracy,
domestic or foreign.
All of the shots came solely
from the sixth floor of this building,
and crucially, there were
only three shots fired.
Three bullets.
- [Lyndon] How many, how many,
how many shots were fired?
- [J. Edgar] Three.
- [Lyndon] Any of them fired at me?
- [J. Edgar] No.
- [Lyndon] All three to the President?
- [J. Edgar] All three to the President,
and we have them.
- [Johnny] The report
says that the first bullet
likely missed the car completely,
but that the second one did
something very interesting.
It first hit the president in the back
and then exited his chest.
It then entered through
the governor's back,
went through his rib, and
then exited through his chest,
but it wasn't done yet.
It then entered his wrist,
shattering the wrist bone,
and then exited the wrist
and went partially into
the governor's leg.
Whoa, okay.
It's quite the journey for one bullet.
Oh, and the bullet in question,
which just apparently made seven wounds,
supposedly looked like this,
which some ballistic experts have said
looks a little too pristine for a bullet
that allegedly just went
through two human bodies.
And then, of course, the third bullet,
according to the Warren Commission,
was the one that delivered
the fatal headshot to the President.
This was the explanation
that the Warren Commission
came up with to explain all of the wounds
that were found on the victims.
All of this damage had to be
done with just three bullets,
and why just three bullets?
Again, ask J. Edgar Hoover
right after the assassination.
- [J. Edgar] On that floor,
we found the three empty
shells that had been fired.
- They only found three
shells up on that sixth floor.
So if all of this damage was done
with more than three bullets,
that would mean that there had
to be more than one shooter.
A conspiracy.
But there couldn't be a conspiracy.
Hoover had adopted this line of thinking
right after the assassination,
this assumption that it was just one guy,
and that line of thinking
endured into the Warren Commission,
a commission that Hoover himself
helped the President assemble.
In the end, the Commission used
a lot of cherry-picked evidence
provided to them by the FBI
that supported their
already-drawn conclusions.
And in the process, they turned any focus
away from exploring all
of the possibilities,
including the possibility of a conspiracy.
The report focuses almost
entirely on one guy,
Lee Harvey Oswald, and his three bullets.
- Who killed John F. Kennedy?
The Commission answers
unequivocally, "Lee Harvey Oswald."
Was Oswald a member of a conspiracy?
The Commission answers, "He acted alone."
- They ignored witnesses that
contradicted their stories.
They ignored or modified
the signed reports
from surgeons and doctors who
worked with President Kennedy
immediately after he
arrived to the hospital
that said that the wounds in
the President's neck-chest area
looked like they came in from the front,
meaning not from this building
that was behind the President.
In other words, the FBI
and the Warren Commission
ignored the advice from that memo
that admonished the government
to release all of the facts.
In my mind, this was the biggest mistake
and the root of all
the conspiracy theories
that exists today.
The question I had in all of this is, why?
Why not do a proper investigation
that explores the possibility
that this was done
by a group of conspirators
instead of just one guy?
For me, the answer to this question
has a lot to do with the greatest fears
that the American government
and people were facing
in the early 1960s.
(tense suspenseful music)
(typewriter keyboard clacking)
First, we have to remember
that 1960s America
was right in the heart of the Cold War,
a time of constant vigilance
of fear of nuclear apocalypse,
of extreme tension between
these two superpowers.
If this assassination was seen
as an attempt to topple the government.
Or even worse, if it had been
organized by the Soviet Union
or its fellow communist regime in Cuba,
that would create a sense of panic
among the American public.
It would be a very different situation
than a 24-year-old communist
sympathizer acting alone.
A believed conspiracy
would also create pressure
from the American public to strike back,
which could lead to an escalation
with another nuclear-armed nation.
Oh, and the CIA also had an incentive
to keep an investigation
from being too widespread.
At the time,
they were secretly conducting
all of these operations
to assassinate Cuba's
leader, Fidel Castro.
This was a big deal and it
was a big secret at the time.
Any deep investigation into
possible conspiracy with Cuba
might reveal that the CIA is trying
to assassinate Fidel Castro,
which would not be good for the CIA.
So one way to read all of this,
the memos, the rushed conclusion,
the emphasis on Oswald acting alone,
the need for there to
only be three bullets,
you can see this as a bunch
of government officials
scrambling to keep the
American public calm
to make sure that
pandemonium doesn't break out
all while reducing the possibility
of geopolitical escalation
with the Soviet Union.
You can see this in some
of these phone calls
where the new president is deeply worried
about keeping the American people united
around a simplified
narrative of what happened.
He's worried that if
alternative theories get out,
it could threaten our entire system.
So their tactic for doing this
was to hijack the narrative
to suppress and influence
the investigation
and make it very simple,
Oswald did it.
That's it.
Here's the problem though.
Eventually, people will do the math
and realize that the government
has been keeping the
full picture from them,
and that's exactly what happens next.
(tense suspenseful music)
(typewriter keyboard clacking)
So the Warren Commission files its report
with the official story of what happened,
but soon after they do so,
members of the Warren
Commission themselves
come out and say like they
don't actually believe the story
that the Warren Commission just put out,
especially when it comes
to the key assertion
that one bullet was responsible
for causing seven wounds.
- I could not convince myself that
the same bullet struck both of them.
- [Interviewer] You
mean that you, yourself,
weren't convinced about
the single-bullet theory?
- No, I wasn't convinced.
- [Johnny] Governor Connally,
the one who was sitting in front of JFK
and the one who was supposedly shot
by that one single bullet,
he disagreed with the story.
- I understand there's some question
in the minds of the experts
about whether or not
we could both have been
hit by the same bullet.
I just don't happen to believe that.
- Even the new president,
LBJ, wasn't totally convinced.
I mean, he was kind of secretive about it,
but he eventually did come out
and tell a reporter from the Atlantic
that he thought that
this was a conspiracy,
that it was Cuba
retaliating against the U.S.
for all of these CIA attempts
to assassinate their leader.
This was not good for the Warren
Commission and their story.
Then, 12 years after the assassination,
this full uncut version of a strip of film
that shows the assassination of JFK,
it finally airs on national TV.
- It's the film shot by the
Dallas dress manufacturer,
Abraham Zapruder,
and it's the execution
of President Kennedy.
- This was the first time
that Americans could see
solid visual evidence of this event,
but why hadn't it been released earlier?
To some, this film contradicted
the official account from
the Warren Commission
and it sparked this new
demand for real answers
from a government that kept behaving
like it was hiding something.
All of this is coinciding with
a time in American history
where Americans are losing
faith in the Federal Government.
You just see this massive like nosedive.
All of the CIA's covert operations
are starting to come to light,
the country is mired in
this endless war in Vietnam,
the President's people were
just found spying on their
political opponents in a hotel in D.C.
Like, the government has not
earned our trust at this point,
so people are like,
"It wouldn't be a far
stretch that the government
was also behind the assassination of JFK."
This was furthered by the
suspicious assassination
of Martin Luther King, Jr.
- Dr. Martin Luther King,
the apostle of non-violence
in the Civil Rights Movement
has been shot to death
in Memphis, Tennessee.
- This was all too much and
the people wanted answers.
So in a shining moment of
redemption of our democracy,
Congress responded by forming a committee
that reopened the
investigations into these
two assassinations, JFK and MLK.
This committee did a real investigation.
They actually were earnest about this
and they confirmed what a lot of Americans
were already feeling,
which is that the Warren
Commission's investigation
didn't sufficiently look
into the possibilities of a conspiracy.
They say it point blank.
They were way too fixated
on their assumptions
that it had to be this
lone gunman that did it
and that their conclusions
were way too definitive,
and then they specifically
call out the FBI and the CIA
for withholding information
from the investigation.
One FBI agent even testified
that he was ordered
by his superiors to destroy evidence.
In this case, a letter that
Oswald had written to the FBI.
- And he handed it to me and
he said, "Oswald's dead now.
There can be no trial.
Here, get rid of this."
- Why was the FBI asking its
agents to destroy evidence?
The committee concluded that
it was a "high probability
that it was two gunmen that fired at JFK
and that it was probably a conspiracy."
That's what it says.
But they stopped short
of trying to determine
who that other gunman was
or who had organized the conspiracy.
And then they once again
make the recommendation
that all of the information
on this topic be made public.
- Isn't it time for the American people
to, at least, know what
happened at 12:30 PM
in Dallas, Texas on November 22nd, 1963?
- Quick caveat, the committee's conclusion
that the assassination
was probably a conspiracy
relied heavily on one piece of evidence,
which was the sound
recording from that day
where you can hear gunshots
and you hear more than three,
and it kind of inferred
that there were like multiple shooters.
This evidence was later challenged
and kind of debunked by the FBI,
but also a different research
facility that basically said,
"This sound recording
wasn't even gunshots.
It wasn't even recorded during the time
of the assassination."
But to me, the whole conspiracy
thing was not actually
the most important part of
this committee's report.
The most important part
was that they confirmed
that the Warren Commission had
been cherry-picking evidence
and hiding stuff from the American people.
After the Congressional Committee
confirmed to the American
people that the FBI
and the CIA had been hiding evidence,
the conspiracy theories rose up once again
culminating in this
movie in the early '90s
that paints an alternative picture
of what could have happened here,
a shadowy government conspiracy
to kill the President,
or at least a conspiracy
to cover up the real story.
- Oswald, Ruby, Cuba, the mafia,
keeps them guessing like
some kind of parlor game,
prevents them from asking the
most important question, why?
Why was Kennedy killed?
Who benefited?
Who has the power to cover it up?
- The film was largely conjecture,
kind of based on some elements of truth,
and some might argue that it
was irresponsibly misleading
to, like, show the American public like,
"Hey, the government
killed the President."
But hey, in a world where the
government isn't being clear
and forthright to the American people,
this film felt like a response.
Maybe the government was hiding the truth,
maybe the government did do it,
or maybe they're just
covering something up.
We don't know because they
haven't released information.
This was a popular movie
and people latched onto the
theories presented in this film.
- The notion that there were
more than one set of shooters
the way that it's presented
physically in this movie
is highly convincing.
- Public pressure got so intense
that Congress finally decided to do
what they should have done in the '60s,
which is force all of these agencies
to release all of the information.
So in 1992, Congress passes this law
that would lay the
foundation for releasing
all of the documents
related to the assassination
by October 2017.
That was the deadline.
They assembled a committee
and gave them several years
to go through all of the documents
and reexamine the official account
and prepare these documents
for release to the public.
We actually talked to the
chairman of that committee.
- I was nominated by President Clinton
to chair the Assassination
Records Review Board.
- In the process of going over
all of this documentation,
this review board found
some more inconsistencies
and discrepancies and instances
of potential cover-up,
like the autopsy.
There's an entire video I could
make about just the autopsy
and the missing brain and all of this,
but the crux of it is that what
the doctors and surgeons saw
moments after the President was shot.
They recorded and they, like, wrote down,
but then what the official autopsy record
actually looked like when it was released
was something very different.
The way the wounds were described,
where the wounds were,
what the brain looked like,
all of this stuff had
been changed or modified.
The photos themselves had
potentially been changed,
and then the brain itself
like literally went missing.
It's like unaccounted for.
So anyway, that's an entire rabbit hole
that you can go down if you want to.
Releasing all these records also revealed
that the CIA and FBI had been keeping tabs
on Oswald's whereabouts,
which maybe makes sense
because he was like a Soviet sympathizer,
but like, why didn't we know that before?
We learned that the Secret
Service had destroyed documents,
the original motorcade
route sheets that they had,
the surveillance tapes from that day.
They had destroyed them.
- Now, we found those documents
in the hands of another agency,
so ultimately there was no harm.
- Judge Tunheim said that, yes,
they got a lot of documents,
but a lot of stuff was still missing.
Like, there was one guy at the CIA
who took control of the investigation
a couple weeks after the assassination,
and all of his records
are just unaccounted for.
- Now, did he destroy them all?
Maybe, I don't know.
There's no real record of that,
so you still have that
previously destroyed issue.
- In total, they finally
released 5 million documents
by 2017,
basically everything except
for a few thousand documents
that the CIA still refuses to release.
Why?
Guys, come on.
You can find this whole
trove of JFK documents
on the National Archives' website.
We'll put a link in the description.
Okay, but here's the
craziest part of all of this.
Even after 5 million
documents were released
to the American public,
to a public that was like
hungry for like conspiracy,
still, there is no solid-smoking
gun evidence in any of this
that points to a conspiracy,
that points to anyone other
than Lee Harvey Oswald
as the person who
assassinated the President
by himself, acting on his own.
Now, the evidence may exist somewhere,
but it's been destroyed or whatever.
The point is, the government
could have released
these 5 million documents in the '60s.
Like, they could have done this
back when people wanted it,
back when they should have,
and it wouldn't have
changed their official story
and it would've satiated
an American public
that was skeptical of their government.
At this point though,
I think it's too late.
The feeling that the
government was hiding something
has now sunk deep into
the American psyche.
We all kind of are like,
"The JFK assassination, yes,
something was up there."
I'm not really sure they're ever gonna
regain our trust on this one
because of how much hiding
of information there was
throughout all of these decades.
So on the internet, all around,
from people who are
actually pretty credible,
you have alternative
explanations that abound.
Maybe it was LBJ who planned it
so that he could be president.
Or what I believe is perhaps
the most feasible theory,
which is that some
rogue faction in the CIA
wanted to take out JFK
because JFK was against
what the CIA was up to.
He was shutting down
their covert operations.
And then there's, of course,
the idea that Cuba did it.
I mean, that's what LBJ, the
president after JFK, thought.
Like, he was like, "It was probably Cuba
because we've been trying to
assassinate their leader."
The point is that because
of the information vacuum
left by the CIA and the
FBI holding back evidence
from the American people,
people started to look at
the evidence they did have
and grasp at any evidence they
could find for conspiracy.
They started connecting
the dots of the witnesses
who met mysterious or suspicious deaths.
Many theorists will fixate
on this mysterious man
holding an umbrella in
this video on a sunny day,
maybe giving the signal
to a second shooter?
It's all very tantalizing,
and some of it is actually very valid
as like leads for further investigation.
But despite a lot of really fishy stuff,
I have not seen any solid evidence
that proves an alternative story
to the one that was told
to us back in the '60s
that Lee Harvey Oswald
was the guy who did it
and he acted alone.
I think it's very plausible
that there could be some conspiracy.
I think we will never know
because we simply don't have the evidence.
One thing I do know for certain though
is that the moment this investigation
turned into an effort
to stifle information
and influence the facts
towards one conclusion,
it laid the foundation for the public
to turn this into a
cesspool of speculation.
Again, I keep going back to that feeling
of being lied to by your government.
It's very potent.
It sticks with you.
It creates fertile ground
for conspiracy theories
of all kinds to sprout.
Because when you feel
like you're being lied to
by your own democracy,
by your own leaders,
no matter the reason or justification,
it makes you feel like you're on your own,
like no one's got your back,
and that you are the one who
needs to find the real truth.
And to me, it's that space
that the most enduring conspiracy theories
find their footing.
(tense suspenseful music)
- Have you ever committed any
act of violence in your life?
- No.
(tense suspenseful music ends)